order order
welcome to this meeting of the council
i'm councillor james caston chairman of
mid-suffolk district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
today
may i first remind you
of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside of the
meeting room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if there's a fire if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the ipswich town football
club training pitch do not re-enter the
building until you are told it is safe
to do so and could you please switch off
your mobile phones or make them silent
and also turn your laptops to silent
we will be um having fines for
telephones ringing in council meetings
of 10 pounds and if i can work out whose
laptops made a noise that will be a five
pound fine
and you may think you've got away with
it but you'll probably get an email
i i would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where those confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also convinced consenting to being
filmed by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded
and if you haven't signed in could you
please do that now
thank you and i'll move to the agenda
[Applause]
item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
pratt and councillor mayer
and i'd like to um take this opportunity
to
wish councillor pratt well
and a swift recovery from his recent
operation and we hope to see him back in
this chamber very soon
item two declarations of interest by
councillors
are there any declarations of interest
um thank you chair as members of suffolk
county council and stone market town
council
are likely to have an other registrable
interest in agenda item 12.
i have granted a dispensation to those
members to enable them to participate in
the debate and vote on this item
thank you
thank you very much
item three to confirm
oh
i apologize
uh
thank you chair um i'm not a member of
stone market town council also for
county council but i need to declare an
interest in item number 12
because i am a
member of the stakeholder forum and i'm
the event director of the children
fields parkrun
which is mentioned in the paper so i
thought i'd better
declare it
okay thank you
right i'm councillor mansell um you'll
need to um leave the room if you have
another registerable interest
um and i think that
i'll
pass it over to the monitoring officer
thank you chair um under the new code of
conduct other registerable interests
where that intra where the item has a
direct
impact on the well-being or finances of
the body in which you have an interest
requires the counsellor to leave the
room and not participate in the vote and
the debate so it's slightly different
to the old regime of local uh
non-pecuniary interests
so i presume you're saying that's the
well-being of the organisation okay
thank you
thank you very much
so now item three
mc225 to confirm the minutes of the
annual meeting held on the 26th of may
2022 for accuracy only
are there any issues of accuracy
could have a proposal for those minutes
councillor hadnam
thanks i'm happy to propose a minute and
could i have a second councillor muller
thank you
all those in favor please raise your
hands we'll do this by
a show of hands
and that's the majority so that's
carried
now item four is chairman's
announcements
i refer you to paper mc226 for noting
um also in addition to this
um these events
our vice chair attended on the 16th of
june woodley community primary school
to celebrate them becoming the first
school in suffolk to become a school of
sanctuary
which is um welcoming
asylum seekers with open arms as
he the vice chair described it to me so
um thank you very much
and
item five now leaders announcements i
would like to invite councillor morley
to present her update councilor morley
thank you chair
as always i want to keep my
announcements as brief as possible
and and in particular i want to do so
this month as we have two really
significant papers on the agenda this
evening
and so i want to ensure we have as long
as possible to discuss
them both
firstly the future of council housing in
mid-suffolk
there surely can't be a more important
time in the middle of a cost of living
crisis
for us to be confirming how we are going
to ensure we provide truly affordable
safe warm
environmentally friendly homes for those
families and individuals who are most in
need in mid-suffolk
and secondly we have an amazing
opportunity
to create a holistic well-being hub
which will bring together education
sport leisure and health facilities
this would be a facility not just for
stone market but for residents and
communities from across our district
and just to mention a few other live
matters
the first
excuse me the first is our current
community engagement in relation to the
parking strategy dropping events are
happening in thurston woolpit stone
market needham market
great blackenum debenham and i
there's also an online survey which we
open until the 31st of july and also
paper copies can be requested by phone
as councillor fleming said when she
launched this consultation our aim is to
have a parking strategy that is fit for
the future
we must ensure shoppers tourists
visitors residents workers and commuters
have access to sufficient
good quality safe welcoming and easy to
use parking
the parking strategy aims to reflect
both the need for private vehicle
parking
and also our climate change ambitions
and support more sustainable transport
options such as buses trains and cycling
in order to connect our communities
as you know we are also currently
consulting residents as part of our new
annual residence survey
the field work for this began this month
and will last for two months
the results of this survey will enable
us to measure some of our short-term
outcomes
such as resident satisfaction
feeling informed influence communication
preferences
personal well-being community resilience
and feelings of safety across
mid-suffolk
i know the report is yet to be
considered for overview and scrutiny
committee which will be happening on
monday but as the papers have been
published
published i want to take this
opportunity
to personally thank the directors of
cifco
the report going to overview and
scrutiny
confirms that cisco sifko generated 3.75
million in net income for mid-suffolk
and baba last year
which of course enables us to continue
to deliver and improve services for our
residents without resorting to increases
in taxes or charges
and i want to finish with three other
thank yous
firstly to councillor brewster
gerard has been a quiet but constant
reassuring support both to me and to the
council over the last three years as
deputy leader
gerald is not the most vocal member of
my group
but his kindly gentle wisdom has been a
big influence
in short gerard has been my rock
he has unfortunately had to step away
from the role of deputy leader for
personal reasons
and councillor richardson has kindly
agreed to step into the role
harry has some big shoes to fill in
replacing gerard
but i'm sure he will be a fantastic
deputy leader i would lo though like to
put on record my thanks to gerard for
all his hard work and i hope you will
join me in a round of applause as a
token of our collective thanks
[Applause]
and i also want to thank and wish good
luck to two of our assistant directors
this is gavin fisk and cassandra
clements last full council meetings with
us
before they move on to ipswich borough
council and east suffolk council
respectively in july
we have seen gavin rise through the
ranks with us over the last 16 years he
has grown with us
however we always knew that at some
point his talent and enthusiasm would
result in him leaving us
gavin has completely transformed and
modernized the housing service and
leaves us in a strong position with the
hra business plan tonight
we wish him all the best over the road
at ipswich
[Applause]
and cass joined us in 2019
and has had a dramatic impact in her
directorate in that time
she has carefully overseen the creation
of a single public realm service for our
councils
has diligently supported our leisure
service through the difficult last few
years during a pandemic
and has of course driven mid-suffolk
forward in our climate change and
biodiversity ambitions
both gavin and cass have been crucial in
supporting the councils through the
pandemic
thank you to both of you and we wish you
all the best for the future and please
do keep in touch as part of our wider
suffolk family
again councillors please join me in a
huge round of applause of thanks for
gavin and cass
[Applause]
thank you councillor morley
now we'll move to item six to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council procedure rules
thank you chair non-received
item seven questions by the public in
accordance with the council procedure
rules again chair none received
so item eight questions by councillors
in accordance with the council procedure
rules
i i refer you to the questions in the
table papers i would like to invite
councillor otton to ask a question
councillor otton
laptop's gone off
um you've got my question in front of
you chairman um the reason i put it in
these terms is that i was absolutely
horrified
to hear a program on radio 4 where
people were having to use
their payment
and go to a pawn broker to actually cash
their payments and therefore
charged a um a fee so in the end of the
day they still were not receiving the
full amount so my question is to
counsellor
whitehead please
i won't repeat the questions you have
all have it in front of you but i
obviously was um
quite shocked when i had this
information from melissa about the
number of people still
not in receipt of their 150 pounds
thank you councillor otton i'd now like
to invite councillor whitehead to
respond
oh
oh it's come back is it all right okay
thank you
uh thank you for your question council
rotten uh as at the 17th of june this
year the council had paid out 4.2
million
to 28 273 households this is around 82
percent of those identified as
potentially eligible
the majority of these council
taxpayers pay their council tax by
direct debit and have been paid
those remaining
are either where there is a mismatch
between the account name and the bank
account name
or the first direct debit is still to be
collected by for council tax which is
part of the prepayment assurance
cases where there is a mismatch which
the council has been unable to resolve
will be written to this week
for those
6741 who still do not pay their council
tax by derek debit
a letter was issued on the 10th of june
the letter signed posted to a secure
online form where there are two options
either to provide bank details so the
council can credit the 150 pound to
their bank account
or elect to have the money pay paid onto
their council tax account reducing
future payments
a three week window is given to
completion of this form and at the end
of the three weeks window
any council tax payer who has not
completed the form will have the 150
pound allocated in full to their council
tax account
as of the 19th of june 46 of caseload
have completed the form
thank you councillor whitehead um
councillor otton would you like to have
a supplementary question yes i certainly
do um i am still really really concerned
about the number of people that are
going to slip through the net on this
but what i would like to know from
yourself or the leader of the council
is will mid suffolk be involved in
establishing the criteria and the
mechanisms for assessing the upcoming
government hardship funds and energy
grants
because i can see
a complete fiasco the rate we're going
thank you
thank you arton councillor whitehead
would you like to respond yes um i don't
have the exact mechanism to hand but my
understanding from just general reading
is i think these future rebates are
going on to either electric gas accounts
and i think there's still some confusion
as to how people say who use oil for
example rather than gas accounts will be
paid but it's something that's obviously
being looked at very closely at the
moment
yes
the chief executive would like to add to
that thank you thank you yeah as castle
whitehead says my understanding is that
district councils won't be involved in
that
thank you we'll now move on to a
question from councillor davies could
you please answer your question i'll ask
you a question
thank you chair so my question is why
can't seal funds be used for feasibility
studies
for community
infrastructure projects and that
question is to our counselor burns
thank you very much councillor bern
would you like to
thank
respond
um
well there has been a cross-party
council
at cross party cross council
uh member working group ever since still
expenditure first started
in 2018
this was following the introduction of
sill in 2016.
this member panel has developed the sill
expenditure framework which council has
adopted
it has been revised each year since 2018
and indeed has been meeting uh in june
this year to agree a revised
civil expenditure framework which will
come and come to council in july
it has long been the view of
the member group that sell funds should
be spent on the infrastructure itself
which is also required by the
legislation
not on feasibility studies for
community-led projects
of course in many communities where
development has occurred
those parish councils receive
neighborhood sill themselves
which they can use to develop projects
through the feasibility stage ahead of
making a bid to the council's cell funds
there is also an opportunity for
parishes to receive support through our
community grants system
and together with the prospect of other
external funding
parishes and other local community
projects
enjoy the potential of different funding
streams to support their feasibility
studies
and startup costs for their
infrastructure groups for infrastructure
projects sorry
the member working group includes myself
councillors mansell and field as well as
council brewster
so if you would like a more detailed
discussion with any of us
or indeed with christine thurlow who
leads on sill from an off office
perspective
then i'm sure any of us would be happy
to talk
thank you
thank you councillor byrne councillor
davies do you have a supplementary
question
yes i do yes thank you for that uh
explanation
uh i have spoken to christine cerello on
several occasions and we'll
take that up again my supplementary
question is
um
why
has uh on two occasions now a
feasibility
been funded for network rail at the same
site
so could you repeat that please yes why
has
still funds been used to
pay for feasibility studies to network
rail
on two occasions at the same site
um
yes uh i think you're probably right
about that and i would need to look into
it to give you a proper response if you
wouldn't mind giving me a bit of time to
do that i will get back to you
thank you very much
um councilman mellon would you like to
ask your question please
yeah thank you chair um
simple question what progress has been
made on the electric bus project which
was agreed earlier this year
and that's questions to councillor
flatman would you like to respond please
thank you councillor melon for your
question
following a discussion with my fellow
cabinet members regarding the research
and development undertaken so far in
respect to the electric bus funding
project we would like to invite all
cancers to a briefing about our state
offices so far and our planned approach
to decision-making including the
formation of a cross-party working group
councillors will receive an invitation
to this meeting later this week
well that could be tomorrow
in addition we have an intern in place
for the summer who is tasked with and
has commenced evidence gathering
specifically in respect of other
regional and national schemes and their
short and long term viability and
sustainability
thank you very much councillor flatman
do you have a supplementary question
council mellon yes
thank you i'm very glad to hear about
the the cross-party working group
since the main i think limiting factor
in getting this project started is the
long lead time for delivery of an
electric bus
should we not quickly decide which model
to choose and get one ordered
thank you chair
councillor
thank you councilman flatman to respond
please
thank you councillor mellon
i think there'll be a lot of viability
studies and a lot to decide on if you're
a county councillor you will know that
the county are leading in a pilot at the
moment on cat catch and
they've extended this pilot to december
and i think it'll be absolutely
what can i say
mad to go down a road that we might have
answered for us as well
thank you
thank you councillor flatman
so to move on to item 9 mc227
the development of the housing revenue
account business plan
i would like to invite council lavinia
hadingham to introduce this paper mc227
this report is for noting and comment
only
thank you
i'm pleased to introduce report
mcslash227
typically a housing revenue account
business plan sets up the priorities
plans and actions for counselling houses
over the next 30 years
our hra business plan was last revised
in may 2017
therefore it is pertinent that after
five years a fundamental review of the
plan and its priorities took place
the purpose of such plans is to show
that we can maintain our existing
housing assets and deliver a quality
customer focused as well as
customer focused service as well as
improve homes and neighborhoods while
supporting and endeavoring to achieve
the visions of the organization's key
strategies
an effective hra business plan has
become ever more crucial since central
government announced the reform of the
rules governing local authority housing
finance and introduction of the
self-financing system a decade ago
members may recall that last year they
were both invited and consulted on what
they saw were the emerging priorities
when developing the hra business plan
this included surveys in a focus group
whilst in january this year a paper was
presented to full council on the
progress being made to develop the plan
and what the guiding principles of the
plan would be
then in may we held an all-member
briefing on the hra business plan for
which we produced a frequently asked
questions answer sheet in response to
members questions today you have the
report and final version of the plan in
front of you which provides
understanding of the revised hra
business plans and its aims and
objectives prior to being presented to
cabinet in july for approval
i'm pleased to promote
the key aims of the plan which include
increasing the stock of social housing
owned by the hra through an ambitious
development program
including on average up to 65 new homes
each year over the next six years
for the next six years
developing new homes that are built to
the highest standard contributing to the
council's effort to ensure carbon
neutrality including an affordable
housing strategy a new build design
guide and technical specification
improving the quality of existing homes
and communal areas
and reduce the carbon footprint of
existing council homes through
investment in assets community-led
regeneration and working with
communities and individuals
including the investment of more than 14
million pounds to ensure every home
meets epc3
epcc by 2030
ensuring our homes and the management of
them maintain and improve wellbeing
outcome for individuals families and
communities alongside other council
services and partners
making sure that hra business plans
continue to remain continue to
continuously remain financially viable
and sustainable
it is vital that the hra has a balanced
financial plan that replays its debt
within a reasonable period of time
therefore we can currently afford to
build 65 new homes each year for the
next six years future itinerations of
the hra business plan and reviews in
subsequent years will determine the
number the number of the council that
can afford to build in year 7 8 and
onwards the exact number that we can
build in year 7 and onwards will be
dependent on continuous reviewing of the
hra finances nearer that time
on an annual basis and accounting for
changes that cannot be predicted today
eg further rises and falls in income or
expenditure
the plan is focused on seven main
priorities which are tackling adapting
to climate change developing new council
housing
investing in our current homes
involving our tenants in the running of
the housing service improving the
services that we provide our tenants
improving the neighborhood that we
manage
and implementing digital transformation
inevitably
inevitably inevitably
there will be challenges ahead including
including maximizing our income which by
25 which by 2025-26
will be as much as 20 million per year
as well as being efficient and
delivering value for money in our
expenditure which by
2025 to 26
will have include having invested more
than 17 million on repairs to cancel
homes more than 23 million on capital
improvements to existing homes more than
62 million on investing in new homes as
well as 33
million pounds of additional borrowing
um and i would like to remind everyone
that this is just uh this report is just
for noting
and to say that um gavin is both there
on his last full council but hazel is
also here to answer questions and emily
as well thank
you thank you councillor hannah
so we'll now move to um questions and
comments um
these
comments will be recorded in the minutes
and will be used by the cabinet in the
next round of this
i would ask the each counselor to um
make
no more than two contributions here just
to keep things moving and to try to be
as direct
as possible with questions and comments
so um i'll open up to the floor thank
you
councillor ebern
um thank you very much chair thank you
councillor hattingham um do you want me
to do questions or comment and questions
combined is that
you can do whatever you like
[Laughter]
how long how long have you got
um
firstly
thank you matthew
um firstly um
i just want to say that i think we all
appreciate the work
that has gone into this business plan
and we appreciate um particularly the
amount of staff house that have gone
into it over time and all the different
ideas that have been put into this
business plan
i think on the um i've got kind of two
main areas of question really
um the leaders already referred to the
cost of living crisis and in the um
report itself we talk about
the um
one of the aims is being to reduce fuel
poverty as well
so one of the things i don't quite
understand is why therefore are we
planning over time to move our
housing stock from
from social rent to affordable rent
because that is much more expensive
in this area than than social rent
and i
maybe i've missed a meeting or something
but i wasn't aware that that had been
agreed as a particular strategy or focus
so i'm very concerned about that and
would would like a answer on that if
possible or if that's something that can
be addressed reviewed or whatever
the second area is in in the report it
refers at the beginning to seven
scenarios but yet in the report itself
it only gives detailed
comment about
two particular scenarios scenario one
and scenario two which then or scenario
five which is then renamed scenario two
which is slightly confusing um but i
just wondered therefore what's happened
to the other
um
and also scenario four was actually
mentioned but not but just mentioned in
passing so
could we have some background really on
what was happened with the other
scenarios are they ones that have been
dismissed um are there ones that um it
was felt they just wanted to focus on
two scenarios within this report um
and and and just to round that off
really
um how then are we going to measure
success so how we're going to say
whether yes we've we've managed to
reduce fuel poverty yes we've got more
people um into very cost efficient and
environmentally friendly
with low costs and so on so how are we
actually going to measure all of this
thank you very much chair
thank you councillor eben councillor
scarf
okay yes please come back
thank you i'm actually going to pass
over to gavin to um you know to give you
your answers thank you
thanks councillor uh having him chair
councillor
e burn um just to try and pick up some
of the points um in relation to the move
to affordable uh apologies if there's
any confusion in both the report or the
plan there is no plan or step change to
move from social rent to affordable in
terms of any sort of blanket policy or
or move so
obviously uh any introduction of
affordable tendencies
would be on the basis of
new schemes coming forward and the
viability of those schemes
in terms of the scenarios um an apology
on my behalf this is been an itty rift
process over a long period of time and
and in the second half of last year we
were focused on a number of scenarios as
you see them so
around delivering carbon uh neutral uh
zero carbon by 2050 that fell into uh to
one of the two scenarios that you see uh
in the plan um then around how many
homes could the the plan afford um you
see that um in in terms of the delivery
of of uh of new homes over the next six
years as council had him as as outlined
in terms of the investor save
initiatives um that is one that uh as uh
as a council we need steam still need to
to focus on um we can see uh through
looking at investor save initiatives and
it describes it in the plan as to what
that investment is
and then seeking a return actually the
cumulative effect the benefit that that
would have on the plan uh over the long
time over the long term so we need to
identify what those potential um
investor and save initiatives should or
could be uh in the future the plan
doesn't propose
what those are
now
the effects of a one-year rent freeze is
scenario two
in the plan uh what was uh scenario five
uh and then looking at a combination of
those so apologies that it's not clear
we focused on those initial uh variety
of scenarios and then we boiled the plan
down to to the two scenarios that you
see in
more detail i think the point to make is
that in terms of a plan this shouldn't
be a plan that is
seen and commented on and and approved
by
cabinets in july and then um you come
back to revisit in five years time in
the same way as the last plan was
developed
this needs to be an iterative process it
needs to be ongoing and it needs to
evolve
every day we know the world in which
we live is changing and as such
rises in inflation decisions that you
will make as a council next year in
relation to rent rises need to be
considered need to be uh taken into
account in the plan every working day
and and it will be for colleagues to to
develop and
scenario test
and robustly stress test the plan uh on
a continuous basis uh as well
in relation in relation to reducing fuel
poverty clearly by improving the energy
efficiency of all existing homes we
would expect
those homes to be more efficient thus
use less energy
and thus less cost but inevitably that's
on on the basis of uh depending on
what's happening with the cost of fuel
electricity gas and oil
i think it's important to know in terms
of the the plan um
this work isn't starting today isn't
starting tomorrow actually has started
some time ago when
you as councils and councillors approved
significant solar pv uh installations
back in 2014 15 um or the fact that
officers are diligently every day
looking at
more efficient forms of of heating um
we're we're installing air source uh
heating uh as we speak uh to to improve
the energy efficiency so i think what we
can do through the work with the energy
saving trust we have a real good
benchmark of of what our accommodation
is uh and how efficient it is
and uh time will tell over over the
coming years as to the improvements that
we can make to those energy efficiency
of those homes
thank you i'm now councillor scarf
thank you chair um well
in relation to scenario two again
actually
page 46 states at the bottom
it will also be important to capitalize
on any opportunities to bring into the
council additional government grants
through schemes such as the social
housing decarbonisation fund
which will support and contribute
towards the cost of retrofit measures
and which have deliberately been
excluded from this financial scenario
work
obviously i understand that you can't
have it in here because you haven't bid
for anything so therefore you can't make
it part of your plan but my question
would be
question one
realistically how ambitious are we going
to be in
seeking opportunities to actually
achieve some grant funding from central
government to decarbonise our housing
stock
and secondly mentioned before when the
housing revenue has been discussed at
ovue and scrutiny committee we talked
about a government grants towards
brownfield sites enabling brownfield
sites to be come forward to deliver
housing
i mentioned at the time one in
particular in stone market which has
seen no housing did have planning
permission on right in the centre of
town um so we didn't achieve anything
with that because we didn't apply so
what how ambitious are we going to be as
a council because uh the director has
just actually said
that we are going to look at every
opportunity day by day
in regards to this how ambitious are we
going to be
in trying to apply for external funding
to help us with our decarbonisation
costs because it would mean that we
could achieve what we want to achieve
quicker and also with less expensive on
that hra account
thank you
thank you the assistant director for
housing
you chair uh thank you for the question
um
i think the reality is that we as as
councils uh babe and mit suffolk have
already been applying uh for uh any
government uh grant through the suffolk
climate change partnership
through the work of colleagues in the
council when we have been successful
we've been successful in a range of
opportunities over the past two years um
i think in terms of where we were
even
six months ago in terms of our stock
we didn't have the intelligence that we
do now through the work with the energy
saving trust and
that has given us a really really clear
indication and picture of every single
one of our houses
based on more than 80 uh 80 different
measures
and we've had staff honing that and
refining refining that every day
i think that puts us in a really good
position because now we with that data
as and when uh the government uh
potentially releases new tranches of of
social housing decarbonisation or or any
other funds will be really well placed
uh to apply for those uh from from the
get-go
and so in terms of that ambition
i would expect us to to be applying uh
and be
being successful in attracting uh some
of those uh funding opportunities um and
as you said uh as you correctly say uh
we couldn't include any potential uh
grant uh within uh within the plan uh
for obvious reasons but as we receive
tranches of funding
and and we know as a social housing
sector that um providers can't do it
alone that the cost of of retrofit is so
significant it will require uh
additional additional external
investment will be best placed um
if i could just take a a moment to to
move away from the question um because
it would be a miss of me uh not to uh
just to to come in and note the the kind
words that were
were given um earlier in the meeting um
16 years is a long time some would
probably say too long
working for the two councils um as
councillor morley describes i have seen
a huge amount of change uh initially
working for baber and then baber mid
i think my reflections are both suffolk
have involved
they've improved and developed to the
councils that they are today and i think
that's testament to all members in this
chamber this evening
members that i may have worked with um
in the past
and to all of our colleagues and and
staff so
i know when i'm talking to to people in
the sector i know when i'm talking to to
colleagues in neighboring councils or
further afield baby mid-suffolk has a
really good reputation and and that's
down to to all of you uh and those uh
not in this room so if i could just take
the opportunity to wish you every
success uh in the future i will be only
across the road so i will be watching uh
and and good luck
thank you
thank you very much um we still have a
question from the council of field
please
looking at the report i see there's a a
comment about average void costs
uh four and a half thousand the sector
average is
5800
so we do well there
the upper quartile performance is 2100
so that doesn't look so bright
it might be just the amount of work
that's done or it might be the
efficiency with which it's done you
might want to come in but the real
question that triggers for me is the
other numbers in this report the
management costs for instance
have we benchmarked then we're going to
other suppliers and where do we stand
there
are we in the same sort of position as
something more than double the upper
quartile performance or are we do we do
a lot better than that
so that's the first question
uh the second one really revolves around
um
rent increases i always get a bit
excited about this advantage at times
i know the plan
intends
as usual to provide
or apply a cpi plus 1
rent increase and there's a scenario
that you've looked at which uh says well
supposing we we um
scrub around that next year we we we
don't do it every year
uh the scenario sort of suggests that
the result will be disaster
which i find quite surprising and you
know it is significant but it's not that
a dramatic gesture
and the point i which concerns me
basically is next year's cpi is going to
be what let's have a guess
12 perhaps so cpi plus 1 is going to be
a 13
rent hike for what are not the richest
people in the world
and are fairly unlikely to be getting 13
salary heights
so that's my allocation of two questions
i guess
the third one i'll keep
thank you very much councillor field
the assistant director for housing
do you wish to come in
thank you chair just just picking up the
the benchmarking one um we have um in
recent times joined house markets a
recognized uh industry uh standard of
benchmarking and so the benchmarking
data that we've been able to add to the
report for the year 20 20 21 um is is
from that it's relatively new we are
validating uh some of that benchmarking
data you'll understand and appreciate
that uh being two separate sovereign
councils and and thus two landlords um
it's important that uh we monitor and
reflect on those costs um and clearly
with something like voids it's made up
of uh both revenue and capital
expenditure so it's important that we uh
refer to and make best use of our
capital
budgets in terms of
new kitchens new bathrooms when
conducted and avoid i think if you look
at some of the benchmarking data
for example around your back office
costs your recharge to the general fund
for for for hr and ict and finance in
the like you'll see that we are really
really lean uh in terms of of those
costs in comparison
to others in the sector so
that's that's a real positive probably
the question is that well it makes it
harder to find additional savings beyond
that in the future uh if we are so so
lean i think
my reflection as the director of housing
and as a housing management team
we know that we've got further to go in
terms of our performance
we um
some colleagues have referred to as as
middle of the pack in terms of jostling
with with other housing providers
uh what we do know with the onset of the
social housing uh bill
is that um the level of benchmarking but
more so the scrutiny of the housing
service both in terms of pound shillings
and pence but more importantly the
safety of our housing and the quality
and the
levels of satisfaction with our housing
from from our residents and and tenants
will be under the spotlight and be under
scrutiny and we've already done work
in recent weeks to collect a baseline
and that's already produced an action
plan to identify how do we make
improvements how do we increase the
levels of satisfaction
that our tenants have with us as a
landlord because frankly
we are striving for for excellence we
need to do more we need to be be better
um and then in regards to just the other
uh question or comment around
rents
yes i think we as a as a nation are
facing unprecedented attempted times in
terms of uh the cost of living crisis
inflation and
it will be a case of in february next
year when you sit down as a council to
decide uh council tax and rent increases
for council tenants there may have to be
some difficult decisions there may have
to be an acceptance that
of decisions in terms of whatever that
increase may or may not be
i think the important thing that i would
know as an officer is
that decision made on that night has an
impact for that year but it also has an
impact for every future year beyond that
and
i know the report that we produced for
february is full council in relation to
uh rents um and forgive me because it's
for this financial year but um it looked
at
a 4.1 increase the impact of not doing
that over 10 years 5.8 million over 30
years
17.4 million so you see the cumulative
effects on the plan
when you're looking at a plan over that
length of time so
i haven't got the answers here today in
terms of what will that rent increase be
they will be decisions that need to be
taken over the course of the budget
setting process for the next year
thank you councillor wellam
thank you chair
um
i'd like to invite the cabinet member to
um
think about what i'm about to say
perhaps give me a response it's about
attendance satisfaction surveys and
measures um
i'm just a little bit concerned about
how good the information back from
doing tenant perception surveys will be
and the reason i'm i'm saying this
is that there are people who
some of my residents who have said to
have complained to me about let's say
gas boiler not fixed
and they've got a they've got a date
the guy doesn't turn up
it's really
a new date is agreed
the guy turns up and he says oh i didn't
realize it was like that i'm not
qualified to do that work
you'll have to
i'll have to send somebody else
and then
the job is done and it's working
perfectly so i asked i asked the tenant
well how do you feel about it oh good
it's really working well so i said well
what about you know the other the other
two days that you had to have off work
in order to sit there and not get the
work done oh it doesn't matter because
it's done now now
that person might be satisfied i'm not
satisfied that that is a valid way
of operating and one one other
one other um may sound a silly case uh
somebody got their back gate it was was
stuck they couldn't get out of their
back gate
um
and so i said right okay i'll open the
gate i'll use a hammer or something i
opened the gate and i reported it
somebody came along new gate
worked well for about three days
um trouble is it then rained
um so
i then yeah i go go back somebody else
comes out sticks again so this
particular tenant says well look don't
worry it'll close in the summer leave it
open in the winter and he's quite happy
with that now i'm not you know as his
representative
i have to say that is not good enough
so can you please let me know that that
there will be a way that you would carry
out the tenant survey so that picks up
on the people who really don't want to
complain
thank you
thank you councillor hanningham oh thank
you yes you're absolutely right keith
that is not um that's not good enough
both both scenarios like you say having
you know saying that you're going to
come and not it's the worst kind of
service you can get and i have spoken to
um in about you know when we've looked
at the house um the benchmarks a
benchmark survey that we've had done
earlier the response times and that they
said that i think it's one of the
greatest um complaints was not people
turning up when they're booked in and i
said that is the worst thing it's a
wasted day of work you know it's
frustrating you know that is one of the
things we really must pick up on and i
hope that we do in the future and um
the gate sticking is
got beggars belief that you know that
they they fitted something that then you
know wasn't fit for purpose and that
without some claiming it whatever needed
to be done if it was swelled in their in
their damp but
that the poor tenant was thinking i'll
leave it open because it's not working
that is shoddy service and i you know i
hope we'll improve it in the future
thank you
councillor stringer
thank you chair uh before i start uh
chair i just want to say i i would have
liked to have asked a question about the
leader's statement but i couldn't put it
on notice because i didn't know what the
leader was going to be saying a couple
of days ago
there doesn't seem to be any space on
the agenda to do that
uh
was it a question for clarification
well um it was well yes it was in a way
in in terms of it it was something that
was in the server don't do it now but
there doesn't seem to be a natural place
to do it on the agenda i will take
questions for clarification but not
questions on the leaders announcements
okay okay sorry
i'll leave it it just
thank you very much
we won't be able to raise uh because the
survey will be over before we can anyway
uh first of all i'd like to make a
statement to say really pleased to see
in the design guide that we are taking a
a a form and function based approach
first a built form first uh approach
uh
that has
consequences if you're going to do a
form-based first
built form first it is going to meaning
probably losing an awful lot of bricks
and mortar you're going to end up with
timber framing and six framing if you
are going to take that approach i
welcome that approach but it does have
consequences
there was just two things within the
built form and uses i would like to
ask why we haven't moved from the aspire
to into the we will
the we are only going to aspire
to have buildings that are accessible to
public transport services and facilities
given that a prerequisite of planning
permission i would suggest that ought to
be in the we will uh
we are we're only going to aspire to
having a design that exceeds the minimum
space standard
i really think we ought to put that in
the we will and and we will only aspire
for there to be wider benefits to the
community in the stuff we build
frankly if there's no wider benefit at
all to the community
we shouldn't be building it it should be
in the we will so i just asked why those
three items are in the we aspire and not
in the we will thank you jen
thank you i'm going to pass this on to
um emily afterwards but i think actually
i'm going to let her i don't want to get
anything wrong sorry
thank you thank you for that question
and the design guide has been um
compiled so we have a number of
aspirational um targets as well as um
the ones that we we've kind of fixed and
would like to deliver the main reason
for that is because we want to be able
to deliver as many houses as possible
within the um
resources that we have available to us
we need some flexibility
around delivering in different schemes
that doesn't mean to say that just
because it's in the aspire you know we
will aspire to column that we won't
actually try to aspire to achieve that
so in some
villages we know that there may be need
for some affordable housing now if those
villages don't have uh the necessary
transport available to them you know
should we not provide houses in those
locations where there's a particular
need so again it's looking very much at
the
uh the details of the situations that
we're dealing with and needing to have a
little bit of
flexibility and we do want to deliver
the best quality homes that we can that
are
sustainable and that benefit their
communities and deliver really good
quality housing that's what we're trying
to achieve the design guide is again an
iterative
document uh technology is changing um
much more quickly than we can
update documents and we need that
document to be really aspirational
flexible and to help us deliver our
ambitions to deliver really good quality
housing for people who need it
thank you
councillor geek
thank you chair um can i ask about the
graph on page 40 the closing stock um
the number of social units in our stock
is the blue triangle and that starts at
around 3 100 units of social housing in
2021 to two
it declines a bit and has a tiny uptick
in 2027 to 28 but then it drops again to
around 2600 units in 2050.
so where are those 500 social rented
units going
am i missing something
the assistant director for housing
please
is
and the sale of properties so invariably
what you see is a a growth of stock
because the the council is building more
homes than it is uh selling through
right to buy um but then there's a a bit
of a cliff edge in terms of the graph
because there's just nothing uh planned
for for year 15 year 20 year 25
what you'll see year on year is you
you'll just see that graph jumping along
each and every year or group of years
so that's the reason why it's
compensating for sales of council
housing but not compensating for stock
that he might be building in 20 or 25
years um just to come back if i could to
councillor willem and and his questions
um um
i'm really disappointed to hear what you
said because personally i'm not happy uh
listening to to those examples
what i do know in terms of what we're
doing within the council
housing services
actually focusing on quality of repairs
customer service
and providing feedback to tenants as
being the three
key
mantras for ensuring that we improve
results across the board and i think
from the survey results that we've done
over the past
12 months because we've had multiple
surveys we can see that there's been a
decline in in some areas of satisfaction
we have also seen areas of improvement
and we can uh pinpoint those two to
actual uh changes that we've made so as
as a positive example one of the areas
in which we've improved is feedback to
tenants and that's as a direct result of
the my home bulletin that now goes to
more than 3 000 tenants across both
districts every month
what we're also doing just to provide
some reassurance we have a complaint
task force it evaluates every single
complaint whether that be a customer
contacting you and you contacting me
or a formal stage one or stage two
complaint
and we do actively make sure that we
learn lessons from from every one of
those examples
and i've got a range of examples i can
give you in terms of changes that we've
made
going forward not only are we going to
be surveying tenants on a very regular
basis rather than
a situation where we had star survey
results in 2019 and then star survey
results in the last six months we will
be going forward asking continuous
questions of tenants on a rolling basis
uh throughout the year um and that will
around a be focused around the 12
satisfaction measures that the social
housing
bill will uh will advocate and and for
which you can benchmark any authority
any provider across the country but we
are going to go one step further so we
are going to ensure that there are
transactional transactional surveys
around some of those areas such as
dealing with your asb complaint at your
recent repair so we will be able to to
monitor
the feedback through that approach and
that will be a mixture of phone
survey postal
and and online
and then just to provide another example
of that the tenant engagement policy
that is on the forward plan for later
this year
its aim is to make sure that tenants are
at the heart of decision making and at
the heart of uh developing the landlord
service um and that's not to take away
from the roles of responsibilities of
every member in this room
but it's most important that i believe
our tenants have a more active say in
the management of their homes the
performance of of us as a landlord so
we have actually just been surveying our
tenants on that draft policy speaking to
the tenant engagement officer this
afternoon
she's come into two boxes of of
responses um on that policy uh alone so
you can expect to see that coming
forward on the basis of feedback from
tenants uh currently being received
thank you councilman mellon
yeah thank you chair um
just a very brief question looking at
the design guide
i see in in the uh
page this is now
anyway somewhere in there it's uh it
says that we will adopt a fabric first
approach creating homes that are zero
carbon ready now this was a new phrase
to me so i was wondering if there could
be some sort of explanation of what that
means i mean i've heard of oven ready
but zero carbon ready not entirely sure
what that means thank
you thank you
i think in terms of zero carbon ready we
are just talking about zero carbon we
don't need the ready on the end um but
the approach is um a fabric first
approach
so something kind of similar to passive
house
and although we have both mandatory and
aspirational goals you know our desire
is to build fabric first
to build properties that are energy
efficient and cost our tenants and our
residents who are purchasing through
shared ownership
less money in the future and part of the
design guide is also quite a lot around
evaluation
so looking at schemes when they're
completed both with the project teams
who took part but also working with the
tenants and looking at the bills and
energy usage of those properties and
comparing them so we have some schemes
that have completed this year with air
source heat pumps that we'd like to
evaluate which is section one of six
schemes that we've purchased from
developers and are some of our own sites
as well just to have a look at what the
energy use is like with the um
air source heat pumps that we can learn
lessons to help inform
these documents for the future
thank you
thank you
councillor mansell
uh thank you chet i'd just like to go
back to uh councillor geek's question
about the graph on page 40. um and i
understand that that's a long-term plan
it goes
25 years
and the actual
business plan that we're discussing
today is really just for the first five
years so i'm just looking at the first
five-year section of that graph
and it looks to me like the number of
social housing units is diminishing
whilst the number of shared ownership
and affordable rent properties
is having a sharp increase certainly in
the first three years so by the end of
the time of this plan we will certainly
looks to me like the forecast is that we
will have a smaller proportion of social
rent properties
um in comparison to our total number of
properties and yet in the answer to
councillor ebern's question we're told
that that wasn't necessarily a policy
that we're heading for so i i we it
certainly looks like in this plan for
five years we will end up with a lower
proportion of social rent properties can
you just confirm that that is what it is
telling me
the assistant director for housing
thank you um it's really difficult on
the on the graph i apologize for for the
sizing of it
i think that the reality of what the
plan
is showing is those right to buy sales
which are invariably going to most
likely be on social
rented properties so thus uh losing uh
socially rented clearly the affordable
housing strategy uh has uh an ambition
to build new homes
ambition to build homes based on
viability and affordability
and that will probably see more homes
built of an affordable rent rather than
a social rent
but i'm sure my colleagues when looking
at schemes we'll be looking at the
opportunities to to build as many social
rent as and when practically possible
based on on scheme by scheme basis
thank you councillor whitehead
thank you
um i wasn't intending to ask a question
and of course this is coming into
cabinet anyway but i think i'll ask the
question now rather than a cabinet
i understand it's difficult to forecast
new bills beyond five years and it's
also difficult to even crystal ball
gay gays the
right to buy
numbers but it seems to me looking at
this graph here that
i think if not in this business plan but
the next iteration perhaps we ought to
assume at least a minimum replacing
all by to rent but sorry all right to
buy housing because
this fall off a cliff i mean it's the
opposite of economies of scale it's
disconnected scale it's the same
management costs on the smaller base
which to me just doesn't it doesn't come
over as realistic so
that's my comment anyway
okay thank you very much um
councillor matheson
yes um
yes thank you chair yeah i was i was
keeping this back until um members had
worked their way through through some of
the um these these other points i think
it's probably more a question for the
chief executive actually but up to um
anybody to answer really and that is how
are we going to
um get the the
the turnover of housing department staff
um
really and and the vacancy levels um you
know under some sort of better control
because this this is this is all very
fine as a plan
um the difficulty seems to me in
actually
carrying it out when when we're you know
running with 15 or something staff
vacancies as we were a little while ago
and um you know particularly with the
losses we've been
suffering at some at the high levels
with special references to cameron
obviously um so i mean how how are we
going to actually control that
the chief executive i think control is
an interesting word and i don't think
you can control that i think the best
you could do is manage that and and
equally
whilst it could be seen as a loss
and it is a loss to us it's obviously
not a loss to that person who's gone on
to do something else with their career
and would
give them the praise and credit and
goodwill when they leave us
as you'll appreciate staff turnover or
turn over recruitment generally and not
just in the public sector is a big issue
at the moment there are lots of jobs out
there and people are
able to go and acquire them they're able
to go and get better paid jobs elsewhere
and at the same time our staff which is
a really good thing are very attractive
in that market but that creates a
challenge for us as you rightly say i
think the figures are wrong that you
quoted and i'm not going to quote
accurate figures because i haven't got
them in front of me but i think as you
said 15 or so
yeah so i'll find out the accurate
figures as we stand today and i'm happy
to circulate those afterwards but it is
a constant challenge absolutely right to
manage as best we can and our intention
always and closure is both gavin and
cass our intention always is to recruit
even better staff when people leave but
that isn't always
isn't always possible
i mean
it was the case that the housing
department was significantly
more more difficult than than other
departments when we looked at these
matters a few months ago in the
opposition briefing i think
yes please just briefly come back you're
absolutely right housing is a particular
challenge is not unique but it's
particular challenge because we find
ourselves competing not only with other
councils which you would expect but we
also with other housing associations who
traditionally
provide a greater package both in terms
of salary and benefits
than local government does
thank you councillor otton
thank you chairman um i just want to
make a general statement really
um as many of you know i have been
accounts of considerable length of time
and can remember
when councils were being
if you like forced to go through the
process
of
not having council housing
and i'm really delighted that the
tenants of mid-suffolk certainly voted
for mid-suffolk to remain their landlord
or their land do i say landlord do i say
land person
so obviously you know there are issues
that we've had to deal with but seeing
some of the reports that we have seen on
the news of quite frankly appalling
social housing being run by so-called
social landlords not just private
landlords i'm actually pleased that we
have control and that some of that
control is in the hands of you know
people that are prepared and are pleased
and if you like passionate about having
social housing and our own council stock
thank you
thank you and councillor ebern this will
be the final person
um thank you chair
for that just a very quick short
question one of the points in the report
was about improving the quality of
estates and managing the sort of area
around the housing which is for the
house
the tenants as well as the community and
these these areas such as pavements and
grass areas and so on matter a lot in
terms of being their upkeep but there
was a very very small neighborhood plan
team of only three people managing that
so my plea would be they'd do a great
job but please if we can get any more
resource
which i know is not a question we're
supposed to necessarily ask for but it's
just such an important area to make
those areas look good and feel good for
everybody not just the tenants but the
general community so if there's anything
we do to to boost that it'd be much
appreciated thank you
thank you very much um at this point
i'll just ask councillor haddingham if
she'd like to add anything
well
okay i'll i'll have a question from
councillor carter
this is the last one
i just hope i can remember it now right
um yes um
firstly to
support the
comments on regards to be surveys should
have declared
jesus being a council of tenants having
not filled in my survey gavin i'm still
waiting for my sink to be fixed since
november
um still
um i did have a
question regards whether or not
the rotation of current tenants we are
aiming to be
providing the best quality housing for
all our tents and there's going to be
some
properties that will have whatever
reason
is not going to be possible to upgrade
it's not going to be possible to do the
retrofits
um
how are we going to go around
are we going to be setting these off
and if so do we need to be doing it
before we start a larger picture of
actually so we don't let me see don't be
seen
like backhand
but not back get trying to get rid of
it's going to be
off-putting to people purchasing
so how are we going to go around about
how we can provide it to entice our
tenants to maybe move to a more suitable
location if that's wherever it but
if that's where their
area is if that's where their support
group is how are we going to entice them
to
be how we can provide them suitable
accommodation in the areas that
they live in
um
and i did wonder as well um
those properties that
we can't sell that we can't
um
upgrade are we going to be looking at
demolishing these properties and
building on the spot these more suitable
properties and how we if that's going to
be a case
how are we going to temporarily house
the tenants that are in this in those
accommodations
councillor had in them um thank you i
think a lot of that will depend i'm
sorry on the individual properties but
i'm going to um pass it on to gavin
thank you chair uh thank you
councillor carter for the question um in
relation to
uh those properties that we've
identified you've got the table in the
report in relation to the current energy
performance of those where we've got uh
properties that are poorly performing
clearly uh not energy efficient and
clearly we'll be contributing to
additional energy costs those sngs
we will be uh identifying those and
recording those so that um as and when
they become available uh for example
through the natural void process then we
might make a decision to do something
different
to those properties we already have a
housing asset review group it meets
regularly to to evaluate all uh our
council housing
in relation to to both buying and
acquiring
as well as disposal
and often it's a case-by-case
basis um i think you touched on another
point which was around
downsizing or moving
or encouraging or supporting residents
to move
where they may have
tires elsewhere clearly we've obviously
got our our allocations and choice-based
letting system for that but i think
there is more that we can do and it does
uh outline in the plan
that actually we should be focusing on
downsizing possibly incentives to to
maximize the use of our stock um
building and
buying more housing to meet housing need
is one thing maximizing and making best
use of what we've already got in terms
of
right house for the right person in the
right location of the right size so on
and so forth is is probably more
important and i think there needs to be
a greater emphasis on that through the
plan
thank you councillor haddon would you
like to add anything
thank you very much um and thank you
everyone that um took part in that and
um thank the officers
for the answers um especially
gavin the usual um
very very clear knowledgeable answers
and um we wish you well in future
endeavors
thank you
so
moving on now to item 10
mc228
the overview and scrutiny committee
annual report 21 to 22. i would like to
invite councillor welum to introduce his
report which is for noting
thank you chair
um
the main part of the report is indeed
the appendix
and that sets out a summary of the
and review of the work that's been
carried out by the way suffocate review
security committee and the joint
overview of scrutiny committee
for the year april 21 to march 22.
our role as a scrutiny committee is to
review areas of service provision within
the context of the corporate plan and
strategic priorities and to hold cabinet
to account
we're also the committee which reviews
call-ins of cabinet decisions and under
any member call for action
additionally we may select the security
the work of external stakeholders and
service providers
we only scrutinize services which affect
some or all of our residents
and only where we expect to add value by
doing so
we scrutinized a range of topics as
those who have read the report would
have noticed
we have commenced a joint review of
transport provision across our district
focusing mainly on rural areas and we
have a joint task and finish group
carrying out that work
the changes to the baba cabinet at the
end of april and early may
uh reduced membership of the overview of
their overview and scrutiny committee
such that there was no baby chair of
scrutiny and an insufficient number of
committee members for a quorum for joint
meetings or for the joint task and
finish group
in complete contrast
i'm pleased to say that the
mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny
membership remain stable throughout the
year and their attendance and support
and the quality of debate have been
excellent
to finish i would like to encourage all
members to consider suggesting topics on
which the scrutiny process can add value
to the work of the council
and members will see that the annual
report is for noting thank you
thank you councillor wellam are there
any questions for councillor welum
councillor staff
thank you chad um well i'd just like to
make the point i mean councillor willem
has uh alluded to the membership of the
joint uh committee which has been
fraught with difficulties
during the year um
we also had a meeting where we had a
joint meeting and uh we fell below three
members of the baba scrutiny committee
so we had to abandon the joint overview
screening committee um so that's two
meetings uh in a relatively short time
where
the work of mitsubishi overview and
scrutiny has been affected by
the membership of our
partnership council
we don't like reviewing things that
affect both councils uh individually but
could he give us some assurance that if
the situation arises again that we
actually moved to a system where we
actually have mid-soft overview and
scrutiny committee meetings without
faber so that we can actually conduct
business which we should be doing as
members of this council
councillor would you like to respond
yes i i think that's a very good idea we
we would have to select those topics
carefully and obviously we would have to
uh discuss with with babel why we are
doing that but certainly we need to move
on we've had a really bad few months
and we can't let that happen again but
yeah definitely that's a good idea
thank you any further questions
is there anything you'd like to add to
counselor welum
i now chair thank you i'm i think i'm
speaking the next item anyway so
i'll speak then about that yeah thank
you
and um that report was for noting only
so we now move to item 11 mc229
which is the overview and scrutiny
committee work plan for
2022-23
i'd like to again invite councillor
wellam to introduce
his report which will be for noting also
thank you chair you have before you were
proposed overview scrutiny work plan
with many gaps
the new joint committee have not yet met
and it would be would have been
inappropriate for the work plan for the
current year to have been drawn up by
last year's committee members even if we
had been able to get a quorum
uh work on adding to the work plan will
commence next week when the new joint
committee meets for the first time
in the meantime you are invited to note
the work plan and i'm perfectly happy to
answer any questions on it
thank you very much are there any
questions
counselor eben
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor wellam
given that the task force on transport
on particularly rural transport started
in september
um which is nine months ago now um and a
regular um task group was supposed to be
meeting on that but obviously hasn't for
reasons that council wellam has stated
with regards to labour councillors
when can we expect that the next meeting
um on that task group to happen
and secondly if i may
there was in the um
it was referred to in the annual plan
about the budget timing
timing of scrutiny of the budget but i
note that in the work plan for this year
that scrutiny is still
scheduled for january so can i'm not
sure if councilwellm can answer this but
perhaps an officer can um when that
scrutiny whether that scrutiny is
expected to be brought forward and is
there supposed to be a change in the um
way the budget process is doing sorry
i'm just looking at council whitehead
thank you very much
i'll go to councillor wellam
thank you very much um yes the task and
finish group had all but finished its
work we had drawn up the draft
final report um we were just waiting for
officers to put that all together and we
were going to take it to the next task
and finish group meeting which didn't
meet so
it's just a case of one one more meeting
hopefully to
to finish that work and then to hand it
on to overview and scrutiny for them to
take a look at
the budget term we well we haven't
entered into any discussions with
officers about
retiming anything anything such as
the the scrutiny of the budget
but i know that
when we spoke with melissa some time ago
she felt that it would be more
appropriate to start much earlier and
scrutinize the process not the numbers
at the end so that will i'm sure that
there'll be no problem there we will be
scrutinizing the process
rather than all the tables that take
absolutely ages to go through and we we
get very little from
um
and if i if i may there's
um
there's there seems to be some almost
overlap and possibly gaps between the
work that over in scrutiny carry out and
audience standards
and i believe that officers are looking
at that so
we we don't yet know whether budget will
stay budget scrutiny will stay with
overview scrutiny presumably it will but
we need to look at all of the other
processes because some are scrutinized
by overall scrutiny some are scrutinized
by audit and standards and we need to
make sure that there's nothing falling
through the gaps thank you
thank you councillor welland
no further questions
oh sorry councilman mellon
yeah thank you chair um i know from the
the forward work plan that you're
uh over and screwing of scrutinizing um
cifco report and and business plan
on next monday
um is there any intention to scrutinize
uh the the holding companies because i'm
not sure where they are scrutinized at
the moment thank you
councillor
thank you for that question
sorry i'll switch me off
um yes that that's possibly one of what
is definitely one one of the areas of
scrutiny that's fallen through the gap
so i don't believe that that um the
performance of the holding companies is
scrutinized at all so
it ought to be considered either by
scrutiny or probably more appropriately
by audit and standards but certainly
that needs to be looked at thank you
thank you and councilwell do you have
anything else to add
and now i need to repeat that if there
are members who have a burning desire to
put something forward for scrutiny
please come and talk to me or any member
of scrutiny thank you
thank you councillor welum that report
was for noting only so that moves us on
to
item 12
mc2210 stone market health education and
leisure facilities i would like to
invite councillor richardson to
introduce paper
mc2210 and to move the recommendations
in the report there are confidential
appendices relating to this report if
members wish to discuss matters relating
to these appendices
can they please indicate as we will then
have to move on to a
public
exclusion part of the meeting
so
councillor richardson
lovely thank you very much chair
i am delighted to introduce this report
and the initial business case for the
stone market health education and
leisure facilities
this proposal known temporarily as the
shelf project represents a significant
piece of work that would considerably
enhance the sporting and leisure
facilities within mid-suffolk enable the
much needed expansion of stone market
high schools facilities and develop a
new innovative well-being hub to enable
the co-location of services with our
partners in health and social care
as members will be aware both our
well-being and leisure sport and
physical activity strategies identified
the need for improved facilities for a
variety of different
sport
sport and physical activities
while growing demand on both education
and health and social care services
requires us to work collaboratively
across suffolk to meet it
particular highlights in the sport
provision of this proposal include a 4g
football pitch
four new indoor sports courts a new
sport pavilion a new cricket square and
a multi-surface perimeter track
it will also include a mini track
athletics facility which we understand
will be the first of its kind in the uk
helping to put stone market and
mid-suffolk on the map
in addition expanding both the leisure
center and stone market high sporting
facilities will not only deliver
benefits for current users but will also
create new opportunities for current and
future residents of our district
i am perhaps unsurprisingly especially
excited about the prospect of a
well-being hub within the heart of
mid-suffolk which will allow for the
co-location of services with a range of
different providers
for those who are able to attend the
site visit to milton hall earlier this
year i hope you'll agree just how
exciting a possibility this is
all of this is especially important as
we move beyond the covert 19 pandemic
investing in our communities and in new
amenities will be a key part of
promoting health and well-being for
people of all ages and abilities in the
future
with that in mind we have we have
engaged extensively with stakeholders
both local and national to ensure this
project delivers the best possible value
for our residents
turning to some of the practicalities
this report is primarily asking
councillors to endorse cabinet's
decision to proceed with this project
and approve the funding of seven hundred
thousand pounds as outlined in paragraph
6.4 to take this project to its next
stage
if approved we will engage in further
consultation and we'll develop a full
business case with the aim that we bring
it back to cabinet and full council by
the end of this year
in summary there is still much to be
done until this project becomes a
reality but if members approve the
recommendations today then i believe we
will be taking a tangible and concrete
step towards it
finally my thanks must go to councillor
brewster and the economic growth and
climate change team i think i've got
that right now
both for the work they've done on this
to date and in anticipation of the work
that i hope is soon to come
thank you chair and i would like to
propose the recommendations in the
report thank you thank you councillor
richardson can i have a seconder
councillor brewster
thank you very much we will now move to
questions
um
councillors um
i would ask you again if possible to
stick to two questions
um
and keep them relevant to the subject
matter being discussed
here um
i think councillor richardson will not
mind
if um the questions are quite blunt and
direct
um to because the we we need we we are
starting to um get a bit behind in this
meeting so um
[Music]
um
yeah so any questions please
counselor american
hello thank you chair um
if i'm really quick and i have three uh
so the first is uh will the fields on
the existing football uh and cricket
area remain an open space for local
residents on the children estates and
surrounding areas
secondly
um the nurse i notice the nursery the
fox club nursery is a stakeholder on the
master plan and i i'm aware that they've
been offered a space in the new hub so
i'm interested in what are the plans for
the existing nursery building that's
already on the site
and
thirdly if i may
the just a question on the mini track
the athletics track uh it looks like
there's space for a full-size track so
why not want a full-size track that
would uh
open it up for more uh national events
etc
thank you
councillor richardson lovely uh thank
you cher uh in terms of the uh fields
where the football and qriket facilities
are currently my understanding is they
will still be open to the public uh in
terms of the existing nursery side i
don't believe there's a plan um as yet
but i'll um
allow officers to come in if they're if
there indeed is one
uh in terms of the actual um the mini
track facility i'll take officers advice
whether this is better dealt with under
the closed session but yes there are
specific reasons why we didn't pursue
that option at this stage thank you
chair
councillor oh sorry
fiona
thank you sorry i wasn't sure if you
wanted me to come in um
sorry um
the in terms of the nursery site um
we
uh we are in discussions with them as
you pointed out um there's no firm plans
for that particular area um but some of
the options we've looked at is
additional play space for example
oh sorry in terms of the uh the
athletics track yeah i don't think we're
straining too much into confidential if
i if i say that
we've had extensive conversations with a
number of uh national governing bodies
and the athletics national governing
body um
wouldn't support a full-size athletics
track just purely due to demand and the
fact that within a reasonable drive time
there are full-size tracks and it was
actually their proposal to look at this
mini track concept which has been rolled
out across europe and scandinavia very
successfully
thank you councillor
thank you very much um
chairman
i think it's a really cracking idea i
think it's a great great that we're
doing this for stone market and for the
whole district um if we were optimistic
when do you think we might determine
assuming all things go to plan which is
always a huge assumption um probably
unlikely but with sensible contingencies
built into it when do you think this
might actually come to fruition assuming
that we do do approve this are we
talking seven eight nine years overall
do you think i mean it's a long-term
project clearly um i'm very very pleased
to see this we've
discussed things like this over many
years as people like um
mrs otten and mike norris will remember
um but i think it's just just a job just
what we need for the district
councilor richardson
thank you chair i think i will um hand
over to officers just to answer the
specifics of that but i certainly hope
with my hand on my heart i can say in
your lifetime counselor
well i better keep on with my rugby
refereeing in that case she'll keep
going for a long time
assistant director for economic
development and regeneration
um
we are
informally projecting by the end of 2025
and that's not to say that some elements
might not have to be phased
but um certainly in terms of the
sporting facilities we would like to say
by the end of 2025.
thank you
councillor ebern
thank you very much chair um thank you
councillor richardson for
this report um with regards to you
mentioned further consultation um and at
the moment the consultation has been
very much concentrated on the stone
market area and with professional sports
bodies
will the consultation from now on
include villages particularly the
villages around stone market because
obviously they're they're developing
their own
sports and well-being offerings and i
wouldn't want them to double up but
equally if they are developing something
that um
can be used um from people in the stone
market then clearly we want to make sure
that's all joined up together so please
could you say tell me when
they'll be consulted on and how this is
going to happen with granted sports
groups in the villages and
paris councils and so forth
secondly um i'm not going to mention
specific costs but when the
in the confidential section there's
details of course but can we know when
will we be able to scrutinize the costs
on the full project um going forward
thank you
councillor richardson lovely thank you
chair um and bear with me if i just um
refer to my uh papers for a moment so
without going into again the specifics
that would take us into the closed
session but we do as part of the
restricted papers have a plan for the
engagement over the coming months that
will include opportunities for everyone
uh to be involved including those in the
neighboring vicinity of stone market
um in terms of
uh the second question about the
scrutiny of the overall numbers are
expectations that that would also uh
come with the full business case so in
other words by the end of the year is
the target date that we've set ourselves
thank you
thank you councillor field
thank you
by the end of the year the feasibility
study of the full business case and
you're asking for seven hundred thousand
that's about ten million years work are
you going to get it done that schedule
thank you chad um but just before i
answer that question just to go back to
council even's point just for clarity
because i referenced it but actually
it's on page 139 that gives the detail
of the engagement plan
um and in terms of uh counselor field's
question
i've been given no indication by
officers why that isn't feasible if
they'd like to give any additional
reassurance then i'd invite them to do
so thank you
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
what assurances can uh councillor
richardson give that sporting
organizations other than those resident
on-site will have unhindered access to
these facilities and how will any such
assurances be enshrined to make sure of
that access
councillor richardson
lovely thank you chair so we've had i
think a number of ongoing conversations
and have developed quite positive
relationships with a number of uh small
providers and clubs and uh teams within
uh stone market in the surrounding area
in terms of sort of these the specifics
and the technicalities of any agreement
um i suspect that would need to be uh
formed as part of the governance
arrangements that will sort of form the
next phase
of this project so that by the time we
come back with a full business case we
can provide you with that certainty
around
access
thank you chair
thank you
councillor carter
thank you
um as one who did attend via emil
hub is that i would be really delighted
if that was we're getting better um am i
mistaking that part of this is uh
well as the school is concerned that
they are unable to maintain the it can
be
well being a wrong build in the wrong
area and they can't look after the
students that's why they were pushing
for the uh for a location for the hub to
be built around it to maintain there
um
and also regards to the
um there were some drive to in seven
years ago the leisure center it was a
unanimous recommendation to actually
level it and build again but it was it
wasn't done so
this leisure center being
old via recently the manager who is
about to be
unable to insulate the
energy and efficiency the lack of
disability access to the upstairs
lifted out of order
i could go on but
with this project we look at possibly
either combining this as was the
recommendation on a visit of combining
the school and the leisure centre to
actually improve the access to to them
or to do a state-of-the-art building
which could be looked at which would be
a benefit to a stock markets
um as it would not be beneficial to
actually
deliver something which we should have
in place already which we say we do have
in place already which isn't fit for
standards
would that not be the idea to look at
doing that first before expanding
um and also
regards to be
i know you've planned sell off a plot of
landscapes
near the school
there has been quite a bit of concern
from local residents uh regards this is
the main drop-off station for students
going to attending a school
when that's been closed before they've
there's been
conflicts with the vehicles parking the
side roads
causing it to restrict access for
emergency vehicles and they've not felt
safe doing so
on daily we do have daily reports of
actually as well people parking in the
leisure centers currently
uh where they pull in and conflicts with
pedestrians on the path as they just
pull in straight away
and the issue of that
the loss of a current parking bay
and also a more restrictive
parking layout how are we going to
compensate how we're going to look at
avoiding these road issues how we're
going to provide
adequate parking which doesn't currently
look like that is going to be
it's going to be more of a concrete
block around it's a bit concerning
uh very final very quickly it does
there's some local concerns regards the
possibility of lots of trees which on
the site visits were discussed it
definitely would be lost now but not
but on the plan still looks as if
those trees are not currently they're
not on the plan the track's still on top
of them so arby's trees definitely still
going to be there and if they are could
we have an updated plan to actually show
what's going to be there
and what's not it's very difficult to
tell by the plan
thank you councillor carter councillor
richardson
thank you chair um i'll do my best to
watch as much as that as i can uh
because it's quite an extensive um
question in terms of firstly concern
from the school i'm not aware of that
being expressed to myself but i'll allow
officers to correct me if i'm wrong on
that uh in terms of the leisure center
so it's a very good point about whether
we can uh enhance the facility itself i
suspect what mid-suffolk will look to do
and it's quite useful that we've got
cass here given the relationship she has
with the leisure center is continually
having conversations with them about how
we can improve uh access and things like
insulation but i suspect given
and again i'm just gonna make passing
reference to what's in the restricted
papers given the um sort of funding
envelope we are looking at um i think
going anything for anything larger more
comprehensive is probably not going to
be feasible um but certainly it's it's a
question worth asking uh in terms of the
sale of the land um what's regarded as
the enabling land within um the master
plan
i think
two there's sort of two things to say is
first of all there is no definitive
agreed plan for what that land will be
used for at present um but second of all
within the master plan there is a
provision for increased and improved car
parking within uh the site for the
school
and then in terms of the loss of trees
um again i think it's almost going to be
too premature at this stage to work out
exactly that level of detail but we'd
expect that to come through uh in a full
planning application or an outline
planning application uh when and if
hopefully it reaches that stage um i
hope that answers to the best of my
ability those questions but officers can
by all means jump in if i've missed
anything thank you chad
thank you very much
and
councillor matheson
thank you chair yes i think this fits
well with what council council carter
has just been um
asking about that the
when
the children raise housing which is as
we know is sort of
halfway through
um
being built out now
when that was being planned and and
started
um
we did not get
the the connectivity of that estate
which of course is right next to what
we're talking about wraps around what
we're talking about here we did not get
the sort of connectivity into the town
for walking and cycling purposes that
that was really needed
it remains poor
um and
really you just finish up on the road if
you're a cyclist um and particularly in
terms of
this hub
we're thinking about
connectivity from the railway station
to the hub and and i think that
i would plead that those
things are taken into consideration and
and
the bus service
uh up children way and and indeed around
um the new estate is is
skeletal minimal um
not very much
so um
yeah if we could get those things
actually
addressed as part of that project it may
alleviate some of the parking problems
that council of carter's talk to thank
you
so
that was a statement and not a question
i don't know if
councillor richardson
yeah i i'm more more than happy to um
that i think with regards to particular
aspects um about cycling and walking we
do have the lc whip the local cycling
walking infrastructure plan coming to
cabinet on the fourth of july so we can
pick up those concerns as as part of
that
thank you very much councillor war boys
right
yeah i've got a general question and and
sort of a couple of specific questions
the general question is um
we've got a table of a number of
stakeholders and sports clubs that are
involved in the proposal
and
i'd be interested to know
the level of consultation that's gone on
and whether
how much um
feedback they've given when they've seen
sight of the master plan
um
there's a i've got a couple of points
about the master plan i'd like to make
would you like me to make those later in
the debate
yes could you please make those in
debate thank you
for richardson thank you chair um i
might have to refer to officers for the
exact specifics about the frequency of
consultation but i think in
in general times i think we can say
there's been a lot of stakeholder
engagement um as far as the master plan
is concerned my understanding is this is
actually being designed in close
consultation with those bodies and they
both local and national have given their
input into it in much the same way that
they were
expressing their view on the full
athletics track for example but if
officers want to come in then i'll defer
to them thank you chair
the assistant director for development
and regeneration
um thank you
so yes we have designed the scheme in
consultation with a huge range of
stakeholders and potential partners and
we set up something very early on
so about eight or nine months ago now
called a stakeholders forum which had a
range of sporting clubs not not just
those on the site actually but um
further reaching than that other clubs
and they have been instrumental in
helping to design this master plan and
they've seen the master plan
a number of times and it's evolved
through their comments and feedback and
equally we have a project group set up
with some key landowners and partners on
the site itself that includes
partners such as the high school
and they also meet monthly they've also
been instrumental in designing this
scheme with with the consultancy team
and ourselves
thank you very much councillor wellam
thank you chair
some of these points or questions have
sort of been touched on but i think
they're still relevant
um you've talked about the consultation
there will be with um
residents of neighbouring villages
but have you had a consultation to
ensure that you're meeting the needs of
neighbouring villages teams has that has
that been taken into account because
there are some villages that have got a
lot of football teams cricket teams and
so on that might need to use the
facility so are you
in this uh development of this scheme
have you taken account of
those existing
teams and so on
because i fear if not there may be a
significant under provision on this
on this side
and have you taken any account of
sports for which there are currently no
facilities in the area there are some
emerging sports um and some sports that
have absolutely no provision and people
have to go to all sorts i'm not
suggesting you have ice hockey there but
i mean i'm aware of a few sports that
people need to have need to travel to
colchester or cambridge for um
so are you aware of all those
um
and uh councilman mathenson
talked about cycling and walking you
mentioned the lc whip but really have
you considered how people will will
access this sports area
by public transport
and also walking and cycling i think to
to say that we're going to look at the
elsi whip in a few months time
that's insufficient have you actually
tried to be blunt now have you actually
done anything about looking at how
people will get there without using a
car
thank you
thank you councillor richardson
thank you very much um so in terms of
the first one about local need i think
what i just reflect on and this is uh in
the report is that what we've
effectively used as our evidence base is
the leisure sport and physical activity
strategy so that was something that was
introduced last year i think was about
the summer
and as part of the
the update to that strategy we
commissioned an external consultancy who
went away and did both a quantitative
and qualitative analysis of both
existing uh facilities demand and
therefore what our
gap effectively is and so we've based it
on that evidence base uh in terms for uh
alternative sports perhaps aren't as
popular currently my understanding is
that a number of these facilities are
multi-purpose so if there are uh future
sports which do become more attractive
more popular than they can use the
facilities we have here um particularly
if i just get the example of the four uh
sports courts that are being attached to
the uh
to the leisure center aren't designed
for any particular one sport in mind but
have multiple different uses um in terms
of the
sort of public transport links to the
site i might need to ask officers for
the specifics but i think the general
point i would make is that
one of the great advantages of this site
is that it is in our largest town that
does have quite good commuter links both
by rail and bus um and so i think that's
kind of a key consideration as to the
general principle of this project is
that it's with all of the sort of right
key stakeholders involved it's in a it's
in a location where there is an existing
need to expand um and obviously there is
the the development next door that um
has
resulted in in close collaboration with
the council so i think in if we were to
look at a site for uh this particular
facility i can't imagine anywhere else
in the district that would be suitable
for it or indeed um is a better place
for it quite frankly but i'll hand over
to officers if they've got more detail
to add to that thank you chair
assistant director for economic
development and regeneration
thank you just to add a little bit more
to the second question um we have
actually been actively speaking to a
number of uh different sporting
organizations that are not um
currently represented on the site if i
gave the example of hockey so we've been
talking to
um i think it's england hockey not
british hockey but um yeah they're very
keen uh there's no presence in stone
market very little presence in mid
suffolk so they're very keen to see how
we could uh set up even if it's a small
club uh operating from the site so yes
we have and that's one of the benefits
of talking uh
to extensively to many many uh national
governing bodies and regional governing
bodies for sports they've given us a
good feel for what
what else we need to put on site
in terms of offer for other sports um in
terms of the final point um we've been
working very closely with our
sustainable travel officer catherine
davis and
we've also had discussions with county
highways with particular regard to bus
routes and buses
there's clearly more work to be done i
think we feel that um
the current master plan has um
indicative routes across the site to
improve connectivity and the next stage
of work very much is how we link it
better into the town centre itself so
that's still work in progress but um it
is being thought about
yeah go on
thank you um yeah i'm glad to hear that
you've taken account of what sports you
know about but that
information may be a year or so out of
date
the big growth area i think around is
the growth of disabled sport so are you
aware of that will you take it into
account please
councillor richardson yes thank you chad
i think the short answer is yes
absolutely the i think one of the key i
think reflections or just general points
about this particular report is that
this is not the end product by any means
that the next phase i think is where
some of the really interesting design
work can uh be done so we can certainly
take that into account thank you chad
thank you councillor stringer yep thank
you
can i thank all concerned for actually
trying to move on the sports provision
in the stone market area and certainly
mid-suffolk i think over over decades
it's not unkind to say that there's been
a number of uh
grand schemes put forward in mid-suffolk
that when they were delivered were a
little bit short of what was promised at
the start
and i would hope we don't fall into
into that trap here uh
just on that note i just wanted to
double check on page 141
that where it says first fist floor i
thought we were going to do boxing for a
moment uh that is a tiger i would take
it uh
the
that because i when it was looking about
changing stuff here i was looking for
the bar
uh because not because i know what to
drink but because that is normally the
economic engine and of awful lot of
sports clubs it means they become
financially sustainable
it raises a slight concern where this
one is now proposed i.e on the first
floor
and the accommodation up there on the
first floor can hold at least 300 people
up there have we checked with the
relevant fire safety officers that that
is buildable
and safe
in that current design because the
design looks quite exciting and quite
interesting
but i'd hate us not to be able to
deliver it for safety reasons thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chair i probably need to hand
over to officers um to answer the
specifics of that one but before i do
that can i just double check
with officers about whether this is
straight into the restricted papers just
because page 141 with the typo that
council string was referring to
on my pack is in the restricted papers
so i just wanted to double check that
we're happy to proceed on that basis
otherwise i'll hand over to officers
thank you
assistant director for development and
regeneration
um so
obviously the building has been designed
by a proper architect in line with
current building standards and building
regulations i haven't specifically asked
him that question i have to say i can
take it away
but
obviously as we go through the detailed
design phase we'll be having
conversations with our building control
team etc
thank you
councillor fleming
yes thank you thank you very much and
this is this is really good news for
stone market and for the district so i
absolutely welcome it um i just
i have one clear question that is um
tennis courts
where are they
because
the current tennis courts at the leisure
center a number of years i have played
on them and um they were pretty rough
then so i'm not quite sure what sort of
state they're in now
i really think tennis is important
especially with the schools
and um i would hope to see tennis
included in our plans and i don't see
the tennis association lawn tennis
association included in in the list of
organizations that we've consulted um so
that that that is my main question just
i can't resist but make a comment i'm
following um councillor stringer's
remarks about the bar having a good
welcoming bar is clearly very important
and um i'm disappointed that there's no
longer a bar at the current leisure
center because i have many memories of
um playing squash there and having a
couple of pints afterwards and you know
i think having a nice bar would be just
such an important part of this
development thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chair i'm certainly learning a
lot this evening
in terms of the the question about
tennis um again my sort of immediate
response is that because we've based
this on the leisure sport and physical
activity strategy that may not be an
identified need um at the time that that
report was commissioned but if um
officers want to come in on that then
obviously i'm more than happy to defer
to them
um so we
sorry so we've um we've been in direct
contact with the lawn tennis association
both both at national and regional level
um and as councillor richardson said we
have obviously based this on uh evidence
gained extensive evidence and audits uh
for the sport and leisure strategy um
there is there is the ability to play
tennis on the multi-use games area but
it will be a multi-use games area so
there won't be any dedicated spaces and
certainly the
national and regional governing bodies
are happy with that approach
yes councillor fleming
thank you i really feel this is an
important
factor especially actually for older
people
as well as teaching young people tennis
worth and tennis club is in my division
and um
wortham is a pretty small village
compared to stone market it's extremely
active and successful um it's well it's
opened it in the evenings it's open to
people who work
and
one of the reasons the need might not
have been identified is maybe because of
the state of the courts um for so long
and need a market i used to play at
needham market tennis courts um if
you've looked at them recently you'd um
you know understand why that's a
complete failure and i think these are
the sort of things we need to really
re-examine
councillor richardson
and i think i'd just say that i agree
with what feminist said and we can
simply take our comments on board um if
officers want to jump in then by all
means thank you
the assistant of regeneration and
project manager
thank you
hi just come back on that i'm sorry the
local club rep we've been working with
as well um and they're happy with their
current provision but they would like to
spend where they are they don't
necessarily want to be separated into
two sites massively but what they'd like
to do work with us is to develop
pathways to ensure that their tennis
arena isn't lost within this project
thank you very much um councillor
amoroson um you have already i think i
counted five questions in your last
one but you um you are very direct and
concise and i like the way you ask
questions so i'll allow you to
come
thank you very much um
it's been touched on earlier when i
asked about the nursery um about uh
younger children's play area
and
with that in mind i wondered uh what
provision might there be for free play
for younger children
uh in the initial plans not just a kind
of um as an afterthought about what we
might do with the nursery as it's as
it's been part of previous conversations
about uh play provision uh regarding the
children lee's estate especially the uh
that end of it
um
yeah thank you
councillor richardson
thank you chair um
i think it's a very valid point um i
don't know whether officers have got any
particular detail but otherwise i think
it's part of the next phase which
obviously is the more detailed design
then there's no reason why we couldn't
include or look to include
that within the scheme itself
councillor eppinyon
thank you mr chairman i'm not sure if
the officer covered this point but just
to assure councillor fleming that we
have a thriving
tennis club in stone market and they're
always looking for members so i would
highly recommend you get in touch
i'm not sure where the question mark was
on on that one
so um yeah but i think that i think
that's it for questions um now
um
[Music]
so um councillor richardson would you
like to add anything
sorry we'll go to debate
councillor ebern
um thank you very much chair
i think it's good to see this coming
forward um it has been a long long time
income incoming and various um members
have alluded to the to the reasons for
that so it is good to see it coming
coming forward i do though still have a
plea um having looked through the papers
i can't find any any word that says
villages will be consulted so i do hope
that the surrounding villages will be
fully consulted and especially with all
of their sports clubs
and well-being activities that they're
doing and that that all of that um
uh
comment as it were from those villages
and organizations and communities around
stone market gets incorporated into this
so we don't have to so what we get here
is is the best we can get and we don't
have to then
redo it in a few years time because
we've missed something
i think
following on from that i would hope as
well that it doesn't preclude the
district from supporting
village
major projects in surrounding villages i
mean to give an example when needham
had artificial pitches put in as soon as
they were put in they were fully booked
for a year you know these facilities
will get snapped up so we need to ensure
that there is support for major projects
in the in the surrounding communities
and i kind of and on the on the actual
master plan
i note the sort of enabling land and i
would kind of urge that we don't look at
this as a priority to use this as
enabling land but use it as
facilities for sporting and for for
well-being and i think that should be
the priority um within within all of
this because this land is surrounded by
housing on all four sides and we're not
going to get any extra land back as it
were so i would hope that that can be
considered in the final plans thank you
chair
thank you very much um council warboys
you very kindly saved your comments for
the debate would you like to go now
thank you chair thank you
uh
yes um
very very specifically looking at i find
it a bit difficult to um
accept the sort of recommendations in
the the master plan because looking at a
few questions
arise personally i
first one is quite a simple one
if i was having a new cricket field i
certainly wouldn't have sort of accepted
the overlapping of a cricket pitch with
a football pitch and um
it does exist at present looking at
google maps which i've just done and
looking at the mowing however it's a new
pitch stone market's got a cricket
club's got an old tradition of playing
first-class cricket and they'd be
wanting to produce a first-class surface
um
so you know the thoughts of the two
sports have got very different needs and
it's both grass but they've got very
different needs in terms of how it's cut
when it's how it's prepared
um that leaves one more second point is
i don't see any sort of capacity for
on-site storage of
maintenance of equipment
or sports equipment for that matter
i have another concern about again this
is on the restricted list but it's a
general point about the changing rooms
really
that there's eight changing rooms
indicated which are fine for
uh for gender-specific games
but quite a lot of sports have
allowed for mixed gender
activities i would question whether
that's an adequate size or number of
changing rooms to allow
four games to take part
some of those games may well be mixed
gender
um
and
again
um i think it is sort of part the
recommendation where you have an
advisory committee being set up which
includes cabinet and ward members um
i feel comf i feel very happy if that
was it extended to people who had a
particular interest in particular sport
and i'm sorry mr pasmos chosen to leave
the building because his passion for
rugby i'm quite passionate about critic
cricket it has some expertise
um
and we've heard from councillor fleming
who's quite passionate about tennis as
well i'd like to see that incorporated
into the master plan
and perhaps that advisory committee
could be extended to those who have a
particular interest
and knowledge
um
and another
issue it's conversations that i've had
with people and it's with regard to the
school
the capacity of the school
i'm going down too long no you've still
got time thank you i'll go on a bit
longer then
i can't hear terribly awesome if you'd
like to wrap up you've still got a bit
of time just to finish that i'll come
it's the provision of the school and the
capacity of the school and
possible expansion of the school in
order to improve its own facilities
um so i think my concern about that is
the future proof
of the scheme whether it is adequate
i'm sure it's adequate for current
provision and i think it's a wonderful
concept
but whether this will
be adequate for future demands on the
site particularly by the school but also
perhaps bikes
encouraging more people to participate
in sport which i think is the whole
purpose of the
scheme thank you
thank you councillor humphreys
thank you mr chair um that wasn't the
elevator that's my mic um i think it's a
wonderful thing i've been involved as
the chair on some of those stakeholder
meetings and they were really good
because actually we did go out and seek
information and involvement from many
sports clubs in fact we advertised
across the whole district and so many
came so we got quite a lot of feedback
actually from not only the residents
because they came as well but also all
the sports clubs around stone market and
the local district area and that was
really good and that allowed you i think
to go away and create your plan which i
think has grown from what i first saw
into something that looks amazing
we talk about the cricket cricket's
already there it already mixes with the
football
pretty much and it works really well and
it's well protected but it's a very good
point and one that should be taken on i
think when we talk about
how do we get there well i don't know
about you councilman matthewson but i
live close to chilton way and i can tell
you that on there we get buses every 30
minutes
so actually they're not skeletal at all
there's really good access plus we're
going to get extra car parking which is
ideal and for those that want to walk or
cycle we've got cycleways and we've got
adequate pavements perfect the most
important thing about this i think is on
4.6 physical activity is the single most
important thing you can do to improve
your physical and mental health and with
25.4 percent of adults in mid-suffolk
doing less than 30 minutes of exercise
per week improved facilities
and integrated support is more important
than ever and as they say build it and
they will come and that's true so we
need to support this
it's really good and actually it's good
for everybody so let's welcome it let's
support it and thank you for your work
counselor emma rosen
oh thank you chair um
just uh to bring up the point uh mr
cancer humphries and uh cancer matheson
brought about the footpaths um it's
already been identified that there's not
sufficient to connectivity between the
new tilt and lee's estate and uh
and
the existing uh especially with regards
to the new school that's on children
leads but also as
children leaves develops further to the
west
yeah i think i think we are going to
need to think about footpaths from that
new uh part of it in to the to the
existing uh
to the uh
new uh shelf uh
facilities
um so um
i'm not sure
so next point i'm not sure if we uh have
covered um the idea of
as a leisure facility are these
facilities going to be open to the
public to use to just walk on site and
use for example you've got if you look
at ipswich and christchurch park they've
got the tennis courts which they take no
booking they they're free to use they're
just like a public facility uh open to
all
and while we're on the point of uh um
of uh championing our sporting uh
passions then certainly uh as a as a
younger guy i was uh very into
basketball um and i know that uh in
within the leisure center there's the uh
basketball uh facility i've never seen
it being used um there's certainly no um
local groups apart from you've got the
berry uh bulldogs who operate out of uh
various um
facilities up that way
but um i'd really like to see a um
open to all outdoor basketball court
that people can just rock up to and uh
and start playing um so if i'm related
to uh to champion uh my sport then yeah
let's uh let's get an outdoor basketball
court yeah thank you
thank you councillor matheson
thank you chair yeah you you've heard i
mean i we do need to improve
the facilities for walking cycling and
more buses we need lots more buses
really
um especially you know with with the
additional number of houses a thousand
something houses being built in the
immediate vicinity
um
but the i mean the
the basic project i mean it's great we
definitely want to do it and get ahead
with it and all the rest of it yes jolly
good all in support certainly be voting
for it
one thing we really need to tackle
and that is a great disappointment at
the moment and that is a whole nother
playing field in the middle of stone
market
formally associated with the middle
school
which has
not
got involved into this project because
of various difficulties that the
assistant director will be pleased to
tell you about a great length or not but
at the end of the day
we cannot leave that field
not
adequately used
to the fullest extent that we can
and so that that will need to be
returned to
so
with that i i
say jolly good project
thank you very much councillor carter
well as we're debating sports i could
always ask uh
which sport offers the best cardio for
any um
elderly fully inclusive
um and obviously that would be as a
counselor
pointed out it's uh it would be
wheelchair sports and we spoke about
before about possibility putting these
on having hiring facilities for adapted
wheelchairs we'd be a first in the
country sports in the country to
actually be able to do if we actually
offered adapted wheelchairs for
for high for everyone so if we can do
that on thirdly support of
of acts it would be one thing to strive
for to actually be able to put forth
we have all these
we have all these sports you have all
these courts and now we have all the
adapted vehicles
everyone can use for that would be ideal
um
the other part i was going to
go for if i can get my brain to connect
what it was oh my tucked up a tongue
five seconds ago
um
i always love it when this happens
oh yes
would you like to me to come back to you
counselor please so i don't dig myself
even deeper in austin no problem at all
councillor wellam
thank you chair um
we won't be the first place in england
to have specially adapted wheelchairs
for sport having played many many many
years ago having played wheelchair
hockey i couldn't confess i wasn't very
good at it and got injured as did most
people were playing
and then my quote my question or my
request is um 3.4 is great uh
yeah really really welcome the uh
inclusion of local ward members but i
think this is something that we're we're
all going to need to know about
so can i plea that gotta give a plea
that
we we're all given regular feedback of
progress the sort of information that we
can give to our residents
oh and and there's tennis courts in
stone upland but
so yeah my plea is that we're all given
regular updates
but welcome the project i think it's
well worthwhile we need to get on with
it
thank you very much councillor muller
i must admit i think the actual walking
routes are actually very good up to that
site i've regularly walked from cedars
park because i don't have a car up to
that site i was there recently for stone
fiesta etcetera and it's only about a 40
minute walk you know right across
the town so i think the connectivity is
actually very good i do fully support
this project i think it's excellent for
stone market and i think it does offer
an excellent selection of sports which
we don't have at the present time so
well done and thank you thank you
thank you and i think that's the end of
debate now
say oh sorry councillor carter i said
i'd come back
um yes i do fully supported projects
this is early days yet and there's more
that we can offer and i look forward to
looking into it in more detail to what
we can offer in future
um i do have to warn everybody that if
we do voters through and we do lose the
current
play area at the rugby field my daughter
will find everybody she will hunt us
down and she will slaughter you in your
sleep that is her favorite
so that is
a
slightly idle threat but
i hope um but yeah fully support this
just needs
iron out some of the kinks some more
reassurance and yes i'll be supporting
it thank you
thank you councillor scarf
thank you yeah very much in support of
the project as a stone market member um
helps to fill a gap that we've had for a
very long time as others have mentioned
but without which without
straying into the restricted papers the
two biggest single challenges i think
that we face with the project
is funding and the shortfall
and secondly the successful management
of the facility once it's in place uh
it's something that hasn't been man
hasn't
been mentioned tonight but there are a
number of ways of managing a facility
such as this and it doesn't appear to me
there's a clear obvious way of doing
that yet so there's a lot of work to do
on that but i'm sure that we can get it
over the finishing line
thank you
and i'll call that the end of debate and
i just invite councillor richardson do
you wish to add anything
yes please thank you chair and just a
few
uh general comments
apologies councillor richardson
councillor brewster reserved his right
to speak would you like to um
make any comments now
i think sorry
i would like to thank uh councillor
richardson for all the answers he's
given tonight
because you know he's done very very
well
um
yes
we were started this project many months
ago now
uh
i think actually it's it's a really good
project
um
and those of us who uh travel to
colchester and then up to um
that
um
we'll see the benefits that we could get
and how we could use it
and you know that that is really um
the bottom point of the the product
and
and i know
that our
um
well
fiona
actually worked on the one at colchester
so i think there is no doubt that
that will carry us a long long way
so thank you
thank you councillor richardson
lovely thank you very much chair um just
in concluding then um a few brief points
um i'm very pleased to see there seems
to be a general consensus that this is a
very positive step forward for the
district notwithstanding some of the
suggestions made
and i'm not one to make promises on the
fly but i think we can certainly look
into
some of those
as the scheme develops
particularly i'm just looking at
recommendation 3.4 um it does obviously
include the creation of a member a
working group so particularly those
councillors who are local so camp
councillors and council humphreys there
will be the opportunity to be involved
as i say as this scheme develops um
and again that is just something i
really would want to emphasize is that
what we're looking at is by no means the
finished product and there will be
further work uh much to be done um so
nothing is actually set in stone so i
very much hope i will not be the victim
of counsel carter's daughter
but
there is obviously i think a good deal
of work to get us to the point at which
we do have a full business case with all
of the um
commensurate funding um and governance
or injuries in place and so again
without wishing to
the uh restricted papers i completely
googled council scarf said those will be
the main major uh challenges um for us
as a council
um and lastly again just wonderful to
hear so many members championing uh
sport provisions within
the district um council revenue i don't
wish to make promises on council
fleming's behalf but i'm sure she would
be delighted to join the tennis club as
long as there is a bar
um and so finally mr chairman just to
really endorse this report to the
council and ask members to vote in favor
and if so then i look forward to
presenting the full business case back
to you all as and when it becomes ready
thank you chair
thank you very much we'll now go to the
vote i will ask the corporate manager
governments and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
councillor carter would you like to give
your vote
okay that's fine
thank you
and cancer gould
four please
thank you that's 28 for that's carried
[Applause]
we'll now go on to item 13 counselor
appointments
are there any changes to placings
no
none thank you
item 14 motions on notice
an unreceived chair
and with that we'll um close the meeting
the date of the next meeting is thursday
the 21st of july 2022 at 5 30
and we'll close the meeting at
8 00
or 7
52.